[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ensemble
il y a pas de saison pour que lui me la
musique au fond pas de saison pour se
vive le sang en marchant tu dans une
case
tu sens la musique au bout de tes doigts
tu dis que la vie qu'on t'a donné
quelque chose grâce au son tu connais
traces ton cœur est dans
sa vie que on a trouvé des festivalents
ton check et tu chantes
[Musique]
jusqu'au bout de la nuit réveil en toi
le tourbillon d'un monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cane se juge pas au plus haut autant
même le temps vieillir
[Musique]
faire du bruit ensemble on y va tout le
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une musique
que j'en mangeais c'est une piste sans
danseur mais si tu rends je t'en ces
moments-là
[Musique]
et j'avais d'étaler la musique était mon
sauvée
je vais garder car n'importe quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'au bout de la nuit réveil en toi
le tourbillon
[Applaudissements]
j'adore